Hello,   LA.
You're   up   way   past   your   bedtime,   aren't
you?
Hope   you've   slipped   into   something   comfortable.
I   know   I   have.
If   you're   new   to   town   or   just
new   to   this   whole   radio   thing,   you're
listening   to   the   Deb   of   Night,   the
only   girl   who   will   spend   the   night
with   you   and   leave   first   thing   in
the   morning,   guaranteed.
Well,   looks   like   the   boards   are   lighting
up.
Aren't   I   the   popular   one?
Let's   see.
Eenie   meenie   miney   mo,   who   will   be
the   lucky   caller?
You've   got   the   first   shot   at   Deb
tonight.
So   who   do   I   have   the   pleasure
of   speaking   to?
Hi,   Deb.
This   is,   uh,   Vigo.
Vigo.
So,   Vigo,   why   are   you   up   so
late?
Um,   I'm   working   the   late   shift   here
at   the,   uh,   yacht   club.
Uh-huh.
How   many   boats   do   you   own,   Vigo?
Two.
Actually,   three.
Uh,   one   is,   uh,   in   the   shop.
I   used   to   do   a   little   yachting
myself.
What   brand   of   yacht   do   you   have?
Um,   you   probably   wouldn't   know   the   brand.
I,   uh,   bought   them   in   Italy.
Ah,   l'Italia   bella.
Parlate   italiano?
Um,
yes.
Arrivederci,   Vigo.
Caller   two,   you're   on   the   Deb   of
Night.
Be   gentle.
Hi,   Deb.
Hello,   caller.
Is   tonight   a   rerun?
Deb.
Caller   number   three,   what's   keeping   you   up
tonight?
Deb.
Listen   to   me,   Deb.
They're   at   it   again,   and   people   have
got   to   know.
They've   got   to   know   because   they   don't
know.
They   won't   report   this   stuff   on   the
news   because   they   own   the   news.
Hello,   Gomez.
What's   the   latest   conspiracy?
Conspiracy?
This   goes   beyond   conspiracy,   okay?
There's   no   word   for   something   as   devious
and   secret   as   this,   you   understand?
The   people   need   to   hear   this.
They   need   to   know   the   real   story.
You've   got   our   undivided   attention.
All   right.
As   we   all   know,   the   Americans   established
a   moon   base   back   in   the   late
seventies.
That's   no   secret.
But   what   most   people   don't   know   is
that   they   have   been   conducting   a   dig,
not   for   resources,   but   for   artifacts.
I   see.
Well,   it's   no   coincidence   that   the   Chinese
have   started   conducting   space   missions.
You   know   why?
I'll   tell   you   why.
The   reason   is   because   the   Chinese   are
trying   to   stop   the   Americans   from   finding
an   ancient   space   probe   sent   by   the
Beta   Centaurians.
And   why?
Because   the   Beta   Centaurians   are   giving   space
technology   to   the   Chinese   to   get   back
at   the   Andromedans,   AKA   the   Grays,   for
giving   space   technology   to   the   Americans   in
the   fifties.
Fascinating.
The   American   government's   been   putting   more   money
into   space.
Don't   you   see   what's   happening?
I   can't   believe   I'm   the   only   one
that's   figured   it   out.
Am   I   the   only   person   alive   that
can   see   what's   going   on?
It's   because   the   Andromedans   and   the   Betas
are   going   to   be   fighting   their   war
in   this   galaxy   through   us,   Deb,   and
the   American   people,   the   people   of   Earth,
you   people   cannot   let   this   happen.
It's   Mu   versus   Atlantis   all   over   again.
Thank   you,   Gomez.
And   that   concludes   the   news   portion   of
the   show.
Well,   this   girl's   got   to   pay   her
bills,   so   it's   time   for   a   few
commercials.
But   don't   go   anywhere.
I'm   just   getting   warmed   up,   or   should
I   say   hot.
Friggin   Chicken   recently   challenged   several   random   people
to   a   taste   test   between   Friggin   Chicken
and   the   other   leading   chicken   flavored   products.
Let's   listen   for   which   one   they   preferred.
Ma'am,   care   to   participate   in   a   taste
test?
Here,   try   this   leading   brand   of   chicken.
Ugh!
Oh,   my   gosh.
Is   that   week-old   fish?
Now,   try   this.
Oh.
Oh!
This   is   some   good   [beep]   chicken.
What   is   this?
Sir,   take   a   test   for   me?
Sure.
Um.
Hmm.
Oh.
Seriously,   job   these   up   your   [beep].
Here,   try   this   one.
Hmm.
Hey.
Mother   [beep]   great   chicken   right   there.
What   is   this?
It's   Friggin   Chicken.
This   is   cat,   right?
Are   you   feeding   me   cat?
Try   this.
Holy   [beep].
[beep]   that's   good.
What   the   [beep]   is   this   [beep]?
Nine   out   of   ten   people   preferred   Friggin
Chicken   over   the   competition.
Why?
'Cause   that's   some   good   [beep]   chicken.
I   mean,   Friggin   Chicken.
Friggin   Chicken.
You'll   swear   it's   the   best   you've   ever
had.
You   love   the   talking   baby   movie   and
the   talking   pig,   and   even   the   talking
car   in   that   show.
You   know   the   one   I'm   talking   about.
But   now   prepare   for   the   most   hilarious
talkingest   normally   mute   object   yet.
He's   Steve   Cash,   a   New   York   banker
and   recent   widower   down   on   his   luck.
And   ten   makes   one   hundred.
Here's   your   money,   ma'am.
Ma'am,   I   happen   to   have   a   glandular
problem.
That's   it.
I'm   withdrawing   all   my   millions   from   this
bank.
Cash!
[laughing]   She's   an   ATM   machine   with   the
soul   of   his   dead   wife.
There's   something   familiar   about   this   ATM   machine.
I   love   you.
Wow,   those   marketing   guys   are   geniuses.
[laughing]   Together,   they're   learning   to   make   the
most   of   their   special   situation.
So   that   girl   from   accounting   used   me
today.
Really?
She   wasn't   like   everybody   else.
When   she   pushed   my   buttons,   she   was
very   gentle.
Oh,   honey,   if   you   don't   stop,   I'm
gonna   have   to   make   a   deposit.
[laughing]
Transferring   Cash,   Wednesdays   at   eight   thirty   in
the   BMC.
Say   goodbye   to   yellow   teeth   and   spots
on   your   dirty   dishes.
It's   incredible.
Look   at   that   shine.
Your   smile   or   these   dinner   plates?
[laughing]   Harnessing   the   secrets   of   ancient   Egypt,
now   there's   a   dishwashing   detergent   so   powerful
it   doesn't   just   leave   your   dishes   spotless,
it   actually   whitens   your   teeth.
Patented   time-release   spiritoids   remove   caked   on   food
and   grease   and   remain   on   the   plate
to   be   absorbed   into   your   food   to
clean   your   teeth   while   you   eat.
Dazatron,   the   dishwashing   detergent   of   the   future,
for   cleaner   plates   and   whiter   teeth.
Last   year,   Democratic   candidate   Michael   Rebens   bought
a   sports   utility   vehicle.
Three   months   later,   there   were   two   separate
incidences   of   hit-and-runs   by   an   unidentified   SUV
in   his   area.
Is   Democratic   candidate   Michael   Rebens   to   blame?
Can   you   afford   to   take   that   chance?
Can   your   children?
Vote   Republican   Senator   Robert   Thorn,   a   candidate
that   has   never   committed   vehicular   homicide.
Democratic   candidate   Michael   Rebens   has   never   publicly
stated   his   opinion   on   child   pornography.
Is   it   because   he's   hiding   something?
Would   you   want   a   child   pornographer   voting
on   this   nation's   laws?
Would   you   trust   your   children's   future   to
someone   like   that?
Vote   Republican   Senator   Robert   Thorn,   the   candidate
that   is   committed   to   locking   up   child
pornographers.
Democratic   candidate   Michael   Rebens   recently   sued   Senator
Robert   Thorn   for   accusing   Rebens   of   being
a   murderous   child   pornographer.
But   Rebens   had   previously   said   he   was
against   clogging   up   courts   with   frivolous   lawsuits.
Wouldn't   this   make   him   a   hypocrite?
Would   you   want   a   hypocrite   as   your
next   congressman?
Would   you   want   your   children   to   become
hypocrites?
Vote   Republican   Senator   Robert   Thorn,   a   candidate
not   accused   of   being   a   murderous   child
pornographer.
In   a   world   where   people   live   and
die.
Do   you   think   you   can   just   go
in   there   and   handle   this   by   yourself?
If   that's   what   it   takes.
He   was   about   to   meet   his   greatest
foe.
Kill   them   all.
All   of   them.
And   a   girl.
Hello.
Hi.
And   a   comic   relief   sidekick   who   won't
make   it   to   act   three.
I   picked   the   wrong   month   to   cancel
my   life   insurance.
No,   don't   say   that.
You're   gonna   make   it.
With   a   guy   from   that   other   movie
that   was   slightly   popular,   and   what's   her
name   from   that   show   you   sometimes   watch.
In   a   movie   with   two   spectacular   CGI
battle   sequences   and   an   advertising   campaign   that
will   leave   you   no   choice   but   to
see   this   film.
See   it   because   it's   a   movie   and
all   your   friends   are   going.
In   theaters   Friday   and   on   DVD   in
three   months